as a person in a leadership position
what should I do if I consistently
notice one of my guys motivating the
team and leading them successfully
during project submissions better than I
can the completion of the mission being
the top priority would it be better for
me to back down and let my counterpart
lead which will benefit the company and
its employees and how will I regain my
status among them I think this is
actually pretty straightforward if
you've got someone that's doing a better
job leading then let him lead let alieve
give him some room learn from him
support them the best you can and the
best way you can most likely support
them is by getting out of the way and
letting them do what they're doing and
then get them the support that they need
and what this is going to give you the
benefit of this now you can instead of
looking down and in and managing your
team you can look up and out and forward
and see what is going on in the future
and prep the battlefield and in the
future or prep the next market area or
look for recruit you know you can move
you can lead you can actually lead and
let that you know Young Buck handle the
things that are going on tactfully on
the battlefield right now I used to say
this to the to the SEAL leadership I
used to say hey the enlisted SEAL
leaders handle the problem that is in
their face right now the tactical
problem that's in their face right now
the officer should be looking at what
we're gonna do next hmm that's kind of a
neat really simple it's not always like
that but that's a real good starting
point and so in this position I'd be
like oh I got a young buck that's coming
up and leading well cool that's gonna
allow me allow me to look up and out and
be ready to move forward and plan the
next move now as far as regaining your
status as a leader you won't really need
to because if you do this properly
you'll be seen as a leader who is
confident enough to let a subordinate
leaders step up and lead while I go and
move forward the you'd have to regain if
you were there shutting this person down
and trying to micromanage and doing a
worse job than everyone on the
team knows that guy could do a good job
mm-hmm let him do it
yes that's about confidence really it's
about like do you have are you confident
and are you secure in your leadership oh
yeah to step aside
yes no problem we love it
hey yo you really good at this cool you
step in there and do it I can Oh
probable that will you get the
occasional person that's like oh look
Jose Jose letting that guy do it cuz he
doesn't know what he's doing
occasionally yeah 1 out of 20 people
will be that big mr. negative that's
fine yeah you know then then what's cool
is when you're on the outside guess what
you are when you're when you let someone
else put on the team guess what you have
guess what you have do test yes Charles
yes and we have detachment and so now
you're gonna be able to see things that
even that leader that's better than you
can't see and then when you come in
you're gonna look like the tactical
genius because you point something out
but they didn't notice because they were
in the firefight technical genius here's
the way it works things good yeah that's
hard to do that man with something doing
better than you you know oh man yeah
that's right I mean the oh I say Tate
what takes confidence this is it's such
a good example of keeping your ego in
check because what you just said
everything feels and when you feel that
that's when you go oh cool I'm my egos
getting out of control it's fine you
just put it in check and let this person
to lead and I'll move you know check out
what we're gonna do next
I'll look ahead on the battlefield I'm
trying to think like oh you said there
occasionally there will be a guy would
be like oh he doesn't know he's doing so
he's let him do I I've been in that
situation or my boss actually I've been
the guy who my supervisor like said oh
yeah you like you to handle you take
this you know you got this one kind of
thing and I'm like yeah you're doing it
cuz you don't know you're doing kind of
thing and everyone knew that and so I've
been in that situation where I'm looking
at them but now think about this
think about if instead of him just
saying hey you go on run this thing I
think everybody said hey echo you're
really good at this
you're better than I am yeah you step up
run this I'm gonna be over here looking
where we're on next what would you think
that yeah so he's actually said that
before like a couple times and it every
single time it made me feel way better
like yeah even though I mean of course
the truth will set you free
yeah so I feel like if I was one of the
domani you know one of the team guys on
the teams thinking that I think I
wouldn't think that if yeah if he did
that kind of stuff or if or if as long
as he didn't act like this is the cure
to heart of leadership the see account
there's all counter-intuitive you think
that if you hide it yeah yeah it's
better mm-hm and the better thing to do
is be like hey echo is really good at
this he's better than I am and he's
gonna step up and run this thing and
people are like oh wow chuckles super
confident is leadership they don't they
don't verbalize in their head that right
that's just the feeling like ya know
chocolates doesn't care who's running
this thank you yeah we're good it's good
man yeah so watch out for that
just keep your ego in check yes sir at
all times